oh thank you so much and I'm very
grateful to these organizers it's
Institute for inviting me to speak here
this is the very first time that I
address the science community now it's a
little bit unusual for my talk so the
first 20 minutes is so much historical
lettuces I know that you guys are
interested in lettuces and then there'll
be some glimpses of arithmetic geometry
things that I do and hopefully I think
you're interested in so this is a
library of the mathematics Institute at
the University of göttingen where I was
Institute most of the time in this
library and there I found interesting
manuscripts and in particular I learnt
about Minkowski so here is makovski in
his
here's just a little bit about this
family
well among his ancestors a judge who
then decided to switch fields and
medicine and practice medicine and then
translated Euclid from Greek into Hebrew
obviously trying to make it more
accessible
then some other ancestor changed the
name and became minkovski and then a few
generations later
Ravi's five children Maxime Oscar Fanny
Herrmann and Toby and well so in cost
himself was born 1864 in Alex Orton that
was complicated it belonged to different
states at different times it enforced
with any event the family moved to
Konigsberg
which was Germany and minkovski studied
that was very very special high school
for mathematics and Sciences in
königsberg and that high school had a
library which had in particular the
Karla journal for mathematics in it so
Hilbert was his friend school and so at
the very young age he won the Grand Prix
a big price of the French Academy of
Sciences for some works that he had
started in high school and talked more
about this then you know our reservists
habilitation became professor and born
came back to Konigsberg as I moved to
Zurich and ended up in göttingen where
he died in 1909 so he died very suddenly
so this is the obituary written by
Hilbert may be hard to read time I'm
going to translate so for six years
every search they punctually at 3 p.m.
we took our mathematical walk as you did
last Thursday on Sunday he suffered a
ruptured appendix itis and passed away
on Tuesday noon this Cirstea again at 3
p.m. we have bird here so he was in his
40s he died as he lived as a philosopher
several hours before his death he was
still proofreading his papers he
deplored his faith as he could have done
so much more but he was also saying that
this latest work on electrodynamics
would perhaps benefit from his Mistral
so I well anyway it's just that you can
look at slide so this is very free art I
mean in Berlin
so it's a cemetery in Berlin now there
is something very special here you see
this red brick so this is the
designation that he is a distinguished
Berliner buried layer or something like
this it's a big distinction which gets
reviewed every 25 years two years ago it
was up for renewal and the city
government decided not to renew it so
there was an exchange
I brought a supporting letter as well I
was asked to be in as a representative
of the science foundation to explain
that minkovski is very important for
Berlin we lost the case but I have my
satisfaction the mayor was removed a
month later so clearly he did not
survive this yes we're getting there so
they didn't help that didn't help now
okay so let's toss his house in getting
in and now his mathematics so Einstein
asked the following question how many
ways added to represent of integers a
sum of five squares okay and this
appeared in this clever journal that
makovski had in his library now the sum
of three squares was kind of understood
sum of five squares was interesting now
when you do with arithmetic geometry and
you're asked to find you know number of
solutions of let's say C as a number of
three squared so you're solving equation
x squared plus y squared plus Z squared
equals C so you homogenized and C equals
C squared and because you're doing
geometry you realize oh that's very
interesting with interaction American
geometry you shouldn't be surprised that
Minkowski came up with this in cos T
space because he was just interested in
representing numbers the sums of three
squares and five squares so this is
where I think it's all coming from now
so that was a big
price question that was submitted posed
by the French Academy they used to have
these competitions whoever solves
whatever that problem gets a prize
and the competition was well can you
solve this problem of time five squares
now it turns out that when they post
this question it had been solved already
like decades before and published in the
leading journal in the UK but since UK
wasn't part of Europe at that time and
so anyway the French didn't read that
leading journal and so there is this
person Henry John Stephen Smith who
actually so said and so okay now a
little bit about this person that Henry
John Stephen Smith now he was the
president of the London mathematical
society he was received many honors and
awards like degrees from Cambridge
honorary degrees Cambridge Dublin two
royal commissions and so on and so on
like leading scientists of that time
right now so interesting from a cemetery
in 1873 he freed himself from the worst
of his drudgery the College lectureship
by accepting a flattering and generous
offer from Corpus Christi College or the
fellowship upon that foundation the
office gave him a pleasant house a small
stipend and not very uncongenial duties
half as master half a servant so this is
how he wanted to live and so it also
says that he was very nice generally he
never allowed his inimitable persiflage
to pass the boundary line into sarcasm
and anyway he also had a speculative
element in his nature that invested so
much money in Minds almost always I'm
afraid and relative that it became
important now and again to eke out his
regular income now so then he became the
chair of the Meteorological Office and
the work was especially congenial
in the first years were so considered
and able as to give a charm to toil and
henry smith's enjoyed the fortnightly
visit to London in the temporary rest
from the turmoil of Oxford business so
the idea that he had to escape Oxford to
get some respite in London anyway so
this is a star of his time and so he
writes to the French asking well what
happened and so that's his paper if the
paper starts with the first word serious
Eisenstein
it's unmistakable eisah style and so
then it's all about quadratic forms and
representation of integers and so he
writes to her meat and it says well
first he consults with his friends you
know I'm a little bit annoyed you know
what what should I do you know
tenderness of feeling and they tell him
oh just right he writes to meet her meet
says Oh Mon cher monsieur there's a lay
it's not me it's some they had no idea
that that was published in the leading
journal circumstances robbery anyway so
there's all of that and they tell him
why don't you resubmit your published
paper so now meanwhile so he decides to
resubmit it so you know to write it up
in a little bit and change this and that
and then he has an accident by riding
and so first he's in bed that he dies so
okay meanwhile her maid says I'm so
sorry okay so that's it so the committee
there in France receives two papers one
from minkovski
this high school student essentially in
front of his establishment imitation now
the conditions where you have to submit
in French in kotsky sends it in in
German and says I'm sorry I have no time
to translate this into French Smith is
working very hard on translating his
stuff into French and then you know
completely succeed and so the committee
gives two prizes
okay now this came up again so here is a
little note from ser in I guess bulletin
of the French mass society or something
where he says so here we are seeing
mathematician al Hmong German
mathematician who writes in French
that's Einstein in the papers original
paper is actually in French
mathematician from England who does the
same then some members of the Academy in
Paris don't read English and then but
they give a prize to a paper submitted
in German against all the rules and so
then sir says well anyway languages are
not that important the ideas are
important and that should be the moral
of the story and the news repeatedly
till can know this could all the latter
for another continue in any event that
keeps coming up even today now so here
are some letters that I discovered in
Germany I took these pictures so
teaching in born when Kasich is teaching
can born and this writing it is quite
frustrating to communicate with my
mathematics colleagues one complains
about headache all the time and another
his wife steps in every five minutes to
turn the conversation to something else
how are you supposed to do mathematics
now
so we said letters to Hilbert from in
cough skip so that's about his
colleagues in bond so this is him at
that time so then he moves to Zurich so
he thinks it's better in Zurich but it's
not much better in Zurich in mathematics
he says I have fourteen listeners and
since most of them are practitioners
applied I have to take great care not to
become too mathematical and lecturing
something between mathematical and
practical mechanics sometimes even more
practical than client would like in
functions you have all the math majors
that is for and here in brackets he
writes this is a - sign and not a minus
sign
okay now among his students what
Einstein and who then wrote with for the
first math physics course that we have
occurred and Minkowski to his assistant
born ah the Einstein well then Stein he
always keep my lectures I wouldn't have
guessed that he was capable of anything
not to mention special relativity and
then he writes well in spite of all my
efforts to adjust to the level of
students and preparations for my
lectures I have fewer and fewer
listeners even the mathematicians of
which there are very few are some are so
busy with various administrative tasks
that they can only swallow what is
forcefully shout down their throats okay
so and so he writes to the Dilbert can
you help me you know leave his place now
of course he had you know very
thoughtful colleagues answers
immediately made him the head of the
entertainment committee of the
mathematical congress that wasn't Zurich
around this time okay
so then I found to his letters Hilbert's
problems famous silber's problems it was
actually mean cost Q's idea that Hilbert
should come up with something like this
so minkovski writes that well though
this would be really really special and
it would be great to try to look into
the future and to specify some problems
which should become challenges for
future mathematicians and so here you
could reach something one would be
talking about you even decades from now
okay now you should pay attention to the
following first of all don't tell them
what you're working on immediately and
secondly the seems of philosophical
nature should perhaps be left for the
German audience rather than the
International and some French
mathematician will probably talk about
you know past and presence and so you
should somehow figure out what Pokkiri
will say
now of course here is the lecture of
Tanqueray on logic and intuition in
mathematics where he talks about klein
the german mathematicians in any event
so several months later comes the letter
well Hilbert formulates the problems and
writes a draft of his presentation and
so here he writes oh dear Freud then
four-track your talk I mean I read this
pleasure and I have to congratulate you
on this it will be a huge success and
every mathematician without exception
will read this and your reputation will
grow so that's Hilbert problems now okay
some some other things from minkovski
publish things so we hear all the time
about making mathematics more and more
as medical so some things that are
aesthetics number series Mattox will
become perhaps state police of the state
of mathematics well but for me I think a
true Horace petition is an enthusiast
per se without enthusiasm no arithmetic
and I'm a great optimal optimus for
arithmetic and there will be a time when
arrays meeting will become truly
foundational for physics and for example
questions such as representation of an
integer of a prime as a sum of two
squares is going to play a role in
physics at at that time mathematicians
number theorists will be appreciate
everybody around now okay so this is
half
but you know what does it mean to
represent the prime as a sum of two
squares well this is quadratic
reciprocity and here's our programs that
the Institute of Advanced Study
discussing you know Langdon's program
and higher is the project in connection
with some problems in mathematical
physics okay so so that's that now about
the work so this is a book I found in
that library that's geometry of numbers
of Minkowski and it's about lettuces so
letter series so you have very rigid
saying slight assistant you have some
geometry and what's the interaction so
okay is counting now I learned about
this theorem of minkovski in high school
here is the simplest formulation you
look at the letters of Koch volume 1
okay so and then you look at the convex
symmetric domain of area bigger than 4
and then the conclusion is there is an
extra lattice point of course a 0 but
there's also something else now that is
the most beautiful incarnation of that
and that's from my high school notes
that how vsync is proved you make little
balls you large them they cover and
things like this so it's characteristic
from in Akatsuki that you know very
general geometric assumption so then you
have a statement about lattice points
now here is an application you look at
the number field so what's the numbers
use the just a vector space a finite
dimensional vector space over Q and well
it's spent by roots of a polynomial of
degree D over there and so it's a vector
space you know how to add and then you
want to learn how do you multiply well
you multiply by whenever you see alpha
to the D you just replace it by this
linear combination the previous powers
of alpha okay so it's a field and it has
the ring of integers it's all those
elements that satisfy an equation with
leading coefficient 1 and all other
coefficients integers now there is the
think of discriminant of a field so it's
a following symmetric expression you
take all the roots you take these
various differences squared
and because it's symmetric in the
permutation of roots you know you can
write it in terms of the coefficients of
the polynomial okay now the latest
theorem lattice point cerium that I gave
you proofs that there are no fields with
discriminant one no such things now what
does it mean in practice I give you a
cubic equation you know what the
discriminant of cubic is minus 4p
squared minus 24 P cubed minus 97 Q
squared is 1
I mean Koski tells you you cannot solve
this in integers P and Q now if I just
give it to you like an algebraic without
any of that background and the lattice
theory and so on and so on it's a
hopeless undertaking it looks like a
math Olympics problem but it's already
hopeless in degree three now imagine I
give you something a degree 10 so these
expressions with symmetric functions I
mean in in expressions and the
coefficients of that polynomial
well how many variables do you have well
as many as you have things here so you
have a huge number of variables big
degrees and I tell you that this
equation this thing equal to one has no
solutions there is no way you can
approach with if you didn't have that
letter Siri in the background so it's
actually a stunning thing now this
result and related results are the
foundation for essentially everything
effective that we know these days in
arithmetic geometry so in one way or
another everything will reduce to
statements like this so now let me give
you some conjectures so you start
counting number fields this discriminant
bounded by B okay the discriminant you
know it's this expression it's there are
finitely many number fields it turns out
is bounded discriminant
so you can ask well how many are there
and well for degree C it was not
classically four and five per gamma did
and then the result of elenberg
venkatesh about on
the number and the conjecture is linear
and it's you know far you don't know
anything and say seven and eight and so
on so okay now so I showed you one
particular equation in two variables you
know for P cubed 27 Q squared so let's
pick any equation in two variables okay
of degree at least three and let's try
to solve that equation equal to one so
the Eagle says there are finitely many
solutions and in fact you can bound the
size of the solutions effectively in
terms of coefficients of F so you're
doing in integral everything the
fountain equations integers so but if
you look at homogeneous equations now
you're looking at rational point so my
genius means you know XYZ are determined
only yeah so then fountains proofs there
are finitely many solutions but you
don't have an effective bound on the
size of the solutions
that's a strange think about this he
proves there is an effective bound not
effective Baker's method that's what I'm
thinking of so the the founding serum
gives an effective bound on the number
of solutions but not on the size I saw
the Baker's method the Baker's you know
actually
so the solution Baker's message I
thought about that applying that all
right so that's an open sink but so what
you could prove so this Bogomolov is
that if you have like effective more
Dell for one very simple curve like this
then you get effective model for any
Hyperloop the curve and so to do it for
one okay now next thing is well how do
you put together spheres and those
you're packing sink and Hales wrote
about this it's hard to read but I mean
you know the story the conjecture we
organized the symposium on evidence that
the Sabbats foundation so you know it's
finite but you don't know so I think you
know the number I mean but you don't
know an effective bound on the size so
you can't find some all a priority
because you don't know when to stop
there is no algorithm I mean there is an
algorithm that will stop but it's not an
algorithm that is not really about a
time of solutions is at most ten your
coefficients but all you do is you find
one solution because when the proof is
ineffective in that it uses ten
solutions to show there isn't in the
eleventh always it so you pay you don't
know any bound on the coefficients of
this solution so you don't know where
that's the problem there's a
contradiction you don't know which way
you win all I see is you bound the
number you don't know when to stop it
will come it will stop but you don't
know where that's so in charismatic
geometry you want an a priori bound the
time in terms of the inputs
see finite generation of the Rings but
is different okay so you don't know
about that by the way is effective that
was not by Hilbert bike bike by others
yeah
camper and let's say pop off but okay so
anyway so we had the symposium at the
Simons Foundation on on Hales who was
working for many years to your right
special software that to check his
original proof and at the time it wasn't
completely verified yet so where he
finished all the calculations the summer
later but it was kind of interesting the
conversation we were having somebody in
the audience as well okay you've got a
verify it on a computer but suppose a
photon hits your core and you get wrong
you know something goes wrong what are
you what do you do that what does it
mean to verify whatever you do on a
computer it's just a machine I mean it
could be wrong it could be some chick in
fact actually I encounter something like
this I had postdoc David Harvey at
current who ran a big computation
computing class numbers cyclotomic
fields and the Texas supercomputer and
because there are so much consistency in
these tables
he found a flawed in the architecture of
the computer it's very unbelievable
actually so there was a systematic error
that he discovered it's written up in
his sink the first time at 63 million in
strength paper was Buller so it was
anyway so it's kind of number selected
computations because there's so much
structure so you get it's not an empty
think about the photon hitting a core I
mean so and then of course it was solved
you know that apples oranges and so on
another thing that Minkowski studied was
polytopes
and he liked polytopes he liked
polytopes these are notes of some
seminars you find polytopes in nature so
this is some animal that likes to
with shape now okay you encounter
polytopes and Lettuce point counts so
for example you want to count number of
lattice points in a polytope you
translate this into some algebraic
geometry and then it's a dimension of
subspace of global sections or some line
bundles that counts number of lattice
points of the polytope and that's kind
of a non trivial thing that you can use
algebraic geometry to prove something
about let's say combinatorics so lattice
points counts and polytopes but
polytopes
of course we states are everywhere so I
just wrote down a few things that some
time to time in asymptotics of integrals
or solitary integrals you find this in
functions in real algebraic geometry but
also a lot of algebraic geometry in
vacations problems minimum model program
you really need to break geometry now
let's go back let's so now talk about
closer to what I do so let's look at
this equation so ABC are integers and
you are asking well Wendell they think
have solutions the integers and the
answer is well first of all you have to
satisfy conference conditions that you
have to have solutions of the reals
okay now but the proof of the rounder
says that the height of the small
solution is bounded by something
effective in the coefficients so okay so
you can just exhaust that bound then you
find your solutions you don't have it
now this again is the basis for
everything else you know about effective
'ti so when you look at the husband
Koski principle you take you know
quadric sand rossi very varieties and
things like this and higher dimensions
everything is reduced essentially to
this and this is the lattice point count
if you've ever thought kind of this kind
of numbers here in class you know it
just
counting lettuce points and there is
some excess and you do this but suppose
you wanted to prove something like this
for this diagonal cubic surface well we
don't know there's no a priori bound in
fact there is no algorithm to figure out
whether or not this equation air
solutions in the integers you can check
local solve abilities that's a finite
problem because you only have to check
crimes at the right you know the
coefficients okay
now let's finally many possibilities you
check it for all the others there's a
general theorem that says that of the
number of variables is bigger than the
degree you always have non-trivial
solutions but in general we don't know
okay so the main questions in arithmetic
geometry is that our interest to me are
either of its local global principles
that have some in cost key principle can
you decide existence of solutions of the
integers from these local considerations
and then can you bound for example the
size of the smallest solution of these
polynomial equations now the other thing
is well related to this let's put things
in the box and count how many solutions
are in a box and then if you have a
family like this ax squared plus B Y
squared plus DZ squared equals 0 you can
view it as a family with the
coefficients ABC varying you can ask for
for how many ABC's do we have solutions
that's another interesting question to
ask and then you can also ask well then
what's the smallest rational point you
know for that somehow now the hata
minkovski principle is in general this
conclusion that you have points locally
for all completions and you have points
globally and it holds for quadric s--
and hyper surfaces of small degree now
there is a counter example I should give
you some proof where as a principal
doesn't hold so ok so this is going to
be a proof so we look at this equation y
squared X 4 minus Z to the fourth so
it's a hyper lipstick curve very similar
to what you've seen before okay now it
has solutions
modular P for all primes but it has no
solutions in the integers solutions as
reals okay so how do you check their
soldiers for all Prime's as I said
before you just check the coefficients
and in this case it's okay so so here's
the proof so we can assume that GCD of X
Y Z is 1 because otherwise to start
dividing by the primes dividing you know
two of them it has to the right hereand
okay you see this one now if P divides
why why so then modulo P 17 is a square
at least okay but there is quadratic
reciprocity 17 is 1 mod 4 so P has to be
a square modulus 17 so every prime that
divides Z Y ok has to be a square what
about 17 so now you look at this
equation modulo 17 everything that
divides Y is a square modulo 17 so
modulo 17 y squared is actually a fourth
power
ok so ok so Y square is a fourth power
we are looking at the equation X to the
4 is 2 times y 1 to the 4 so we're gonna
raise this equation to the power 4 so we
find X 2 16 is 16 y 1 to the 16 more
than 17 Fermat's little theorem this is
1 this is 1 and you find the equation 1
is minus 1 so that means there are no
solutions in the integers for this
equation okay so that's the proof so
what have we used apart from trivial
manipulations the real input here is
with its theoretic reciprocity that's
the only non trivial if you like input
into this example and you could try to
do something like this in higher
dimensions so I showed your curve so
this is a surface so this for example is
a family of conics
but Y squared the Z squared and one
coefficient changes in this particular
fashion so just a family of conics so
it's a surface and this surface happens
to have solutions modular all primes but
no solutions over the integers now this
is another surface the cubic surface
similar to the water chute use the
diagonal one it has solutions modular
primes but no solutions globally and so
how do you do it well you use some kind
of quadratic cubic reciprocity and so
the visibility of class numbers and
things like this so there is a general
framework that deals with these
questions and it's the brower groups so
what is the Brauer group
well we've seen you know conics before
and colleagues they can either have
points and not have points so a brown
group sits so we view this conic is kind
of an representative of a brown goop the
brown group is something that would
classify we thinks that geometrically
for example conics or projective spaces
but not over the ground field in any
event there is this functor from schemes
to groups it's a brown group and once
you have it kind of a factor you have
arrows between these things and in
existence of a point over the rationals
will give you an arrow from here to here
existence of local points will give an
arrow from here to here but then there
is kind of a basic exact sequence here
and so an abstraction to the existence
of point here and simply that for every
local point you end up in here there's a
non zero element and that can actually
be computed so you go through this kind
of diagram okay so the rational points
will lie in the intersection of all
these things and the brower aren't
obstructed adele's local points and well
it can be analyzed
so manning who formulated this gives a
much more systematic approach to these
local global principles and identifies
algebraic structure behind the
obstruction and so we worked it out we
looked at you know some other surfaces I
showed you this colleague bundle which
is a degree for no patch to surface the
cubic surface is classical this is the
next on the list
the degree to depetro surface is a
classification of surfaces and in fact
we got interested in an algorithmic
issue here is there an effective
algorithm to compute this abstraction
and what you showed is that there is one
so for geometrically rational surfaces
there is actually an effective algorithm
with a priori bound the time based
I mean bounded time as a function of
coefficients so for example here we can
effectively compute the brahmani
abstraction and we can effectively
determine when the set is non-empty of
brahmani and unobstructed points we
still don't know we still don't have an
algorithm to determine when the sink is
solvable because and that's a big
conjecture in the field
RVC only obstructions and the conjecture
is that there are now we've also looked
at integral points not only rational
points look at this equation here we
find that the solutions mod p for all
crimes but no solutions in Z however
solutions in Q that's kind of cute so
you can solve it in rationals you can
solve it module primes but not in the
integers look at this equation there are
no abstractions to solving this for many
n for example n equals 33 but no
solutions are known by computer and I
had my postdocs run the computers pretty
high I mean at that time you know they
exhausted you know power but so
conjecture would be the trial solutions
but you can't find any
okay so anyway that is general sink
which says that the brahmanyam
abstraction to existence of rational
points should be the only one there's a
lot of work on that conjecture and you
know some partial results a way so then
if we had that then you would have an
effective algorithm to decide so that's
one thing
existence of solutions then you can ask
well how many solutions are there you
can try to count lattice points in
symmetric domains and as you can imagine
it's volume plus error term so then you
want to compute the volume which is easy
in this case but not so easy for general
sinks and then you want to show that the
error terms are smaller than the main
term so in this example if you look at
lattice points up to plus minus one and
also under the Assumption GCD is 1 then
what you're counting is actually
rational points on p1 because as I said
to the homogeneous thinks you don't
distinguish things that differ by the
same vector so you can represent the
point here as X 0 X 1 this co-prime
integers coefficients up to plus minus 1
ok so now I've accounting lattice points
in this ball growing ball and so the
area is PI R squared so PI B squared in
this case and then you have to account
for plus minus 1 that's 1/2 and then you
have to count for Co primality that's
one of the data too now why that because
the probability of dividing both x0 and
x1 it's 1 over P 1 over P it's 1 over P
squared so the other probability is 1
minus 1 over P squared and then you
multiply over all Prime's and that's
what you get so now what is this it's
this times this and then this is
actually number of points in P 1 or a
finite field divided by P 2 the
dimension which is 1 and then some
regularizing factor this is how
interpret this and so this is what you
see in general you want to count
solutions on algebraic varieties
solutions of these equations that have
any
then you find this in the leading
constant so p1 so why p1
well p1 is sort of the simplest things
that we can think of and there are many
ways of thinking about p1 you can think
of p1 is a compactification of the a
fine line you can think of P wine is
computed occasions of a Taurus which is
the fr line - 0 invertible elements or
you can think this as a flag variety
variety of lexus pijl - over the braille
subgroup so and you can also think of p1
as representative of what's known as the
petal surfaces like a cubic surface or
complete intersections of small degree
and products of projective spaces and
things like this or even more generally
the richness notion of rationally
connected varieties where every pair of
points is connected by p1 and obviously
on p1 everything is connected by p1 but
in higher dimensions there is more space
for these rational curves and so then
you know a chain of p ones so the
counting problem then becomes you have
your variety it's solution of a system
of polynomial equations you put it into
some projective space you fix some
height function which is like square
root of sum of squares of the
coordinates and then you ask well you
know how many points do you have
and the asymptotic is B to the a log B
to the B minus 1 and to some constant C
and you could try to apply with general
conjecture and practice and the favorite
example is cubic surfaces in particular
single cubic surfaces so here's a
picture of what the cubic surface looks
like if you make it singular so the
different singularities you can you know
go from here to there and you're looking
for lattice points that happen to lie on
these shapes right so I think the
picture shows that it's really kind of a
non-trivial problem because you know
lattice points are so it's a lattice and
then to lie on something like this is
not so easy and the answer is you always
get B log B to the 6th
where does that come from so then you
can try to plot your solutions so you
pick an equation like this and you ran
it on a computer so you get points
scattered all over you see you know
there are certain accumulation places
here for the points but otherwise that
somehow distributed so well and you can
prove it
so in this case my student there in town
serviced interpreters browning establish
the asymptotic formula and the leading
constant looks like this number of
points over a finite field mod P divided
by P squared again this regularizing
factor which this time is the service
power then this thing which looks
difficult but is actually simply the
real analog of this thing this integral
a twisting they're essentially the same
the computer turns the same fashion then
there is a constant which is 1 in this
case but not 1 in general and then there
is another constant here which is the
volume of a certain poly tope how do you
get this poly tope you take a cone of
effective divisors you slice it by a
certain hyperplane section which is anti
canonical class dot something equals 1
you get the polytope and that's the
volume of the polytope so it's a problem
from linear I don't know something
programming or whatever so that spits
out these kind of constants in
asymptotic formulas now these cones of
effective dividers that can be very
complicated so you get rather
complicated
so I printed another set of solutions
another equation here and so there is a
whole industry counting points on
surfaces many many people browning
Febreze Brown Morozov Berger so that's a
big Africa Varia so finally you want to
know what are the constants in B that
showed up and there is an explanation a
dramatic explanation for all the
invariance involved in particular for
the distinguished anti canonical
embedding which for the cubic surface is
simply the standard American to p3 is a
cubic hyper surface you find B to the 1
log B to the B minus 1 where that little
B is the rank of the peak our group the
geometric invariant of the surface that
can be computed effectively so there are
many results and a groups erratic
context for counting rational points and
there are many results for counting
integral points and Peter Roosevelt is
this
for many years so what this conjecture
here suggests that if you want to look
at the smallest point you see this is
the asymptotic for points of bounded
height well you think that when you look
at that height up to be that the points
don't really accumulate I mean you don't
expect the points to be accumulating
heroes here you expect them to be kind
of active distributed between 0 and B so
if this is the number of points up to
height B then what's the smallest point
so the smallest point should somehow be
related to well that constants that
we're seeing here and so you can try to
tease it out from numerical data and so
the height of the smallest point so
here's a plot for you know some depetro
surfaces final 3 folds and so on so this
is a typical plot so how should you read
this of course you can always cook up
the coefficients in such a way that you
have kind of an a very very small
solution with large coefficients you can
say like a thousand
X cubed - 2001 y cubed so clearly you
know 1 and 1 this minus that so you can
always match things but if you take
typical coefficients and you try to
satisfy your equation then it's not so
easy and then it's kind of really
related to the Tommy Gavin number which
is the product of these local densities
that I wrote down so this is the
tamagawa number this is the product of
local densities and that's the height of
the smallest point so you see that
dependence so in the McCammon number
it's a product over you know number of
points or refiner steel to repeat of the
dimension regularize properly and then
similar thing at infinity as well so
that comes what I said you always you
can always cook up points of small
height by doing strange things
choosing a surface for that so you can
get points of very small height right
but for large coefficients so to speak
by cooking them up in such a way that
the difference is small so that's kind
of the non typical behavior but then
once you get into so okay so to
summarize you know what is there is
magic geometry so there is this
interplay between these lettuces rigid
structures and geometry and you try to
understand how you know how to put
lattice points on these geometric shapes
then so what kind of techniques do we
use well first of all to get any
conjectures we always run things on
computers the big computations so when
trying to find these asymptotes X of
points of bounded height so you've seen
an asymptotic which looks like B Times
log B to the sixth so how do you find
numerical is at log B to the sixth so
log B to the seventh right so you need
to explore pretty high up and so we
actually did it in some specific
computations where you have to you know
your points are integers you have two
integers of science you know ten to the
sixth on to the certain so on and so on
and so on and then you try to satisfy
these equations your for variable
so you get very quickly into so but
finally when you want to prove your
predictions so what kind of techniques
to be used so we use massively harmonic
analysis so on the dells representation
series either harmonic analysis or
non-cumulative harmonic analysis so we
analyzed spectral decomposition of some
generating series and well harmonic
analysis you use representations Theory
you need to know something about
representations that show up in the
non-communicative setting and then this
analytical algebraic geometry is a place
rule because already in those
interpretations of the constants there
are those which terms that you may not
know affective divides our speaker
groups things like this well this is
what comes out so maybe for sort of
down-to-earth computer science so you
take your favorite matrix let's see
upper triangular matrices right and you
look at an algebraic representation of
such a thing let's be even simpler
Heisenberg group you know X Y Z you want
to understand the orbit of this under
some algebraic representation you can
put it into very high dimensional space
by simply putting this matrix into some
much much larger matrix right
representation then you look at the
orbit and then you look at lattice
points on this orbit and our methods
produce asymptotics for the number of
lattice points on these very very thin
orbits and high dimensional spaces you
get precise formulas there's these kind
of invariants that we can sort of pre
compute now that ought to be relevant
for something in computer science
because again if I had to draw you I
mean the shapes of these orbits they're
very interesting in fact algebraic
geometrically there are no
classification schemes for these if you
look at the unipotent groups like up a
triangular groups then the model I
spaces of these representations they are
sort of wild there is no good theory for
that so now that's it and I wanted to
finish with a
quote from my friend and co-author
Maxine could say which so very often a
mathematician considers his colleague
from a different domain this disdain
what kind of perverse joy can this guy
find in his unmotivated and plainly
boring subject I've tried to learn the
hidden beauty in various things but
still for many areas of source of
interest is for me a complete mystery so
my theory is that too often people
projects their human weaknesses
properties onto them as a medical
activity there are no obvious that are
obvious examples on the surface for
instance the idea of a classification of
some objects is an incarnation of
collectors instincts the search for
maximal values is another form of greed
computability decidability comes from
the desire of a total control think
that's mostly relevant for yes
fascination with iterations is similar
to the hype lattissima Fred McNew cick
of course the classification of some
kinds of objects could be very useful in
the analysis of more complicated
structures and so on and so on and so on
anyway so I hope thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
I was curious about your reference to
the mistake that occurred doing bearing
calculations was due to the factors in
structure and the calculations and there
was one bug that was repeatedly so
screwed up the calculations because
there was because of structure right so
there was some back in the computer in
the supercomputer that they discovered
because class groups there is so much
internal structure there that you when
you produce these tables you want to
reference the cross-reference and match
and when you discover there is some kind
of systematic mistake then well you
check and recheck there's a mistake
there must be a mistake somewhere it's
not been the hardware and they found it
and they write about it in their paper
and that I found really striking oh you
wouldn't have seen this otherwise if you
do climate or a forecast you're not
finding this kind of systematic mistakes
because okay cloud it should be there it
shouldn't be there but when you do
number number fields class groups say
you don't have clouds I mean it's so
rigid research but verify calculations I
mean he took cause more generally and
the idea was that he had another program
which was simpler it's a quantifiable
way since that would verify exact
calculations it's so even the trivial
example like GC Lisa I think that was
this prime example in the beginning
there was a TI calculator and he spit up
GC and apparently goes above but they
never checked it so there was never a
checked at that she did was correct it
would just be you know something quit
the Euclid's equation equals d and they
devised it so this brought up a whole
area of research so I was just wondering
you know even without finding the bug it
because in this example they found it
okay because the cost thing you didn't
work but in some sense it's consistency
checking out so so what's the name of
the book so it's not the book it's their
paper by job Euler and the David Harvey
it's called the 163 million
cyclotomic fields supercomputer it was
in the heart where the back was to the
heart every processor several times of
two to be sure that it's really bug in
the heart where they did with a random
the first time they saw the problem they
they thought okay but then if you do it
repeatedly it you find the same issue
then there is something in the
instructional issue yes so that's all
the chance you would have two errors
that kind of consistent with each other
it's unlikely right I think some of the
theories you use that logic I was
impressed I mean I'm not supercomputing
there but these guys fear and that they
ran into this that I'm striking you say
where these conjectures of money
actually falls in some cases point is
that being weakened sound we know where
to expect
oh there is a lot of work even recent
work from last year by Tanimoto layman
and others to understand the geometric
constraints coming out of - conjecture
can do metric consistency of these
things I mean there was a counter
example of victor battery from myself
some 20 years ago to a strong form of -
conjecture we found that
axis of didn't predict we got it from
geometry that wasn't apparent at the
time the conjectures are formulated now
okay there is now a different
formulation that what account for our
country example but of course and there
is even one instance a recent paper by
his brother browning where they prove
theorem about well okay the equation is
ax squared plus B Y squared plus Z
squared plus DT squared equals zero so
it's now quadric s-- in four variables
and now ABCD and XY DT there are
considered as variables so you're
sitting sort of in p3 times p3 and you
have a hypersurface of by degree to two
so you can either view this as a family
of quadrants this way or the family
colleges like one - sorry it's like ABC
is linear and the XYZ is quadratic so
and in this is the first instance where
you see this kind of accumulating
behavior that would contradict -
conjecture and they prove the version
the modified conjecture in this case so
that at least one instance which is very
hard actually where paper is very hard
is the spectacular paper but so there's
hopes that the geometric in issues that
have been identified will cover in fact
everything so that your models the
complete pictures to what should be true
may be mentions when we expect many
points but I have to say that you know
particular the conjecture predicts that
points are dense in risky topology for
example if you don't know that for
certain hyper surfaces take a
hypersurface of degree 5 and p5 the
points are supposed to be dense
let's say after some extension of the
ground field and you don't have any
tools for proving this so not to mention
- conjecture even density we can't prove
yes so Petzl herbs like the cubic
surfaces the conjectures for the anti
canonical thread what happens if I bury
this over the amplicons so there is the
precise conjecture due to yes absolutely
so are you right so okay so correctly if
there is so there is a distinguished
anti canonical embedding so this is your
P car okay so and you could take a
different line bundle that gives a
different embedding into projective
space let's say this is so then the
constant a in the action talk is going
to be B to the a log B that B to the a
log B to the B minus one so the a is
this number here so a times L plus KX is
on the boundary of the effective cone so
it's this number here so that when you
take this vector multiply this a or
exactly here this is the effective cone
shifted by the NT canonical class so if
it specializes to the previous case when
L is minus KX you're finding a is equal
to one and that would be B to the one
that's the linear growth now the log
here it's the co dimension of the face
that you're hitting absolutely this is
what it is this is it's a trap in the
middle model program in fact it's called
for jitta energy it's what happens for
Jesus version of the minimum model
program because if you had the ample
cone instead that would be directly
maurice special thing but because you
have the effective cone it's like it's
fujita ample to the fact if I related
ampulla society effective is little bit
bigger in general and so so yeah it's
it's a pretty geometric picture so it's
a nice
yes so you mentioned this has one career
as a minkovski principal and you had
some specific equations for it it's
false
oh that's a wonderful question there are
papers on that actually how many ABC DS
or how many members of your family
that's first of all do you have local
solvability for all primes and secondly
when you have local solvability do you
have this bromine in abstraction layers
Prime's so let me give you one thing
that's so that maybe appeared in some ok
x squared plus dy squared plus DZ
squared right you want to understand ABC
so that you have solutions okay so when
is it that you don't have solutions you
don't have solutions if a prime divides
one of the variables here into this over
with maybe - is not a square knot a
little prime so what's the probability
for that
well dividing is like 1 over P and then
squared not clear it's like 1/2 and then
well it could be a B or C they have
three things that has like three halves
and then you look at the 1 minus that
and you look at the product and so
eristic argument tells you it should be
well maybe only cubed over something
like log base 3 halves right that's what
you would get from this kind of oiler
product it's actually very hard to prove
there is a proof over the rationals but
you want to do it over a number field
there is no proof now this is a special
thing you can look at more general
families where you have like families of
conics not over a two-dimensional base
this is ABC services p2 projective space
we have a family of conics over p2 with
ramification along three line
certification means that the line equals
zero the chronic collapses so it's kind
of the generate the conic drops rank
allow the three lines now you can look
at arbitrary base space
and you could look at families of
carnac's or families of you know other
things like this so that has been
addressed now finding the brahmana in
obstructed sink that's much tougher so I
try to do that for the family of cubics
this one cubics plus let's say D T cubed
equals zero many many years ago you
don't get interesting logs you just
change a constant a little bit so but
indeed you can show that you know
general members and some family positive
proportions of them of course satisfied
don't satisfy local abstractions for all
primes and then you can other point on
the no points I mean the bar gamma in
this is liberators worked on that a lot
go get somebody
yeah studying for that conjecturing
obsession is basically the only
obstruction
oh that's a beautiful question so I well
the arithmetic is governed okay take a
cubic surface twenty-seven lines of the
complex numbers have you have you do you
all know how to get to twenty-seven
lines
well anyway so you get one line first
and you you know twenty-seven lines of
the cubic surface so but over no closed
field there is a Gallow action all those
27 lines and then we say we can compute
effectively Brown right abstraction the
first step in this direction is to
effectively compute the action of the
Gallo group in terms of the coefficients
so this boils down to computing the
Gallo group of a polynomial of high
degree okay so and then the next step is
you compute something called the Gallo
kamala G so the 27 lines span we think
we just called the peak our group which
for the cubic surface is Z to the 7 ok
the interesting part is like Z to the
sixth because the anti canonical class
it's so canonical that it's sort of
Gallo invariant always you can look at
its complement mr. specters intersection
pairing so that letter Z to the six that
knows about the action of the Gallo
group on the lines ok so there is like a
group comala gh1 the gradall group
acting on that thing this is an
abstraction to now the key of the think
of the ground field and so on and what
Curatola and his collaborators are
thinking that well this should be this
is the things that's staring us in the
face this should be the only abstraction
somehow now of course when you go deep
into the theory it's it's much more than
that so they have developed something
called the theory of universal tossers
which I should probably explain to this
connection if you look at the projective
space like p1 and I said like x0 x1 I'm
actually thinking that I'm taking fi and
plain a 2-0 and divided by the
multiplicative group so avataric variety
can be written as a quotient of a
nephron space - something like this by
some multiplicative group so what they
discovered that when you do descent on
let's say a cubic surfaces you find
you've probably seen gang form at the
central curves you want to show that X
cubed plus y cubed becomes EQ cube has
no solutions how do you do it you split
it into product of linear forms product
of linear forms is the cube therefore
each linear form has to be a cube you
get extra equations it's still a curve
now when you do it for surfaces the same
thing now you have X cubed plus y cubed
is equal Z cube plus T cubed you split
it into linear forms and you start
writing auxiliary equations but you get
us a higher dimensional variety in fact
of dimension 2 plus 6 in the dimension 6
it's like a family of taurah of dementia
6 over the base so what they conjecture
is that that total space is a rational
variety of the ground field that would
explain the uniqueness of the brown
Manion abstraction and they have proved
it in some very special circumstances so
well business for the pets the surfaces
in general so those are the things that
you get running the minimum water
program of an all closed fields in
dimension 2 for geometrically rational
surfaces so the motivation and why did
they seem that the think is rational
because downstairs with garlic homology
is abstract incorrectly but the baby
stores are constructed upstairs and
thusly proved there is no Brower group
for the total sake well if there is no
brown group if there are no coma logical
abstractions to rationality they thought
well that should be rational so and now
they produce it they show it in one in
one case they can prove it or connect
bundles before the generate fibers they
can prove it so the first example that I
had there is a skorsky counter example
that x squared plus y squared to the
polynomial f of T Z squared if F has
degree for the conjectures are settled
if F has degree 5 or 6 it's totally
unclear so but there is a lot of work
it's been 40 years you know people have
tried attempting
all right
[Applause]